this is chelsea anyone this is chelsea
against an all stars of the world and
golocante makes it as a player i think
for being always actually probably just
edges kante as a dm brother
stop
smiling at you you couldn't even say
that with a straight face
no i think on the ball he's better than
kante and i think defensively there's
not too much of an argument but the two
different things
yeah
yeah for being young
what
[Music]
you again my mate as much as i love
seeing you and your company is obviously
something that i dream of at night i
mean this is not going to be good for me
but let's let me explain what we've got
to do here so you got your both teams
and you have to pick a combined 11. if
you both can't agree i
have the final decision you're the king
i'm the king brother today
i want to start with the right back
position because i think okay that's
probably where it's going to be most
tricky oh did happen i reckon you don't
think i like reese james i do i think
he's bosch lads i'd actually love him in
the liverpool squad as a backup i think
that'd be amazing i really really might
be asking i don't know no it'd be rich
change restraints would definitely be my
shout here train alexander arnold is a
phenomenal footballer like absolutely
phenomenal footballer the question is
is he a phenomenal defender do you do do
you think that this is undoubtedly you
know what it is i really think james's
ability is you know i always say he's
the second best right back in the league
and i think he's actually one of the
best right backs in the world so i don't
want it to seem like that i'm just
disregarding them in a way but it's
because
believe this but that's a steady old
time he's playing against 13 of the best
players every year with the champions
league in the top four that he's playing
against and you don't get fanned out no
i think he's a lot i don't think he's a
bad defender at all i don't buy into
that narrative i think it's i think he's
very lazy to just simply say he's not a
good defender because he's a good
defender this is why i like rory
but what i would say is that when you
look at that brilliant liverpool back
line yeah
he is definitely the side that you
attack he is definitely the win it's not
that he's the worst link he's not the
weak link tool because he's a phenomenal
footballer who contributes so much to
the team
but he just isn't as good as a defender
or say andy robertson at least jameson
cross he can shoot and stuff like that
but trent can do all the same things you
know you saw this goal that scored
against newcastle he's got the most
assists in the league
i think that's significant what's he
added to the right back position what
hasn't he added to the right back
position is what you should be asking in
terms of the passes that he springs from
here to here this is what i love the
weight sport bar but well done to you
i'm going to let you know where the play
he passes from over there he switches
the ball the way that he plays it down
the line and even the little through
ball that he gets through here
unbelievable
yeah it's amazing so this is one steve
i'm afraid i'm not going to fall on my
sword here i'm standing true sorry james
reese james so that's what we're going
to
do
i'm going to hurry
up
there
the last thing i'm going to say before
you come up with your answer
statistically trent is better trophies
trent is better going forward trent is
better and i think defensively it's very
very close so i'll let you go
as you go bree strange is currently
champion of the world and champion of
europe currently but he's never won the
league and that's not his fault if we're
going to go downstairs it's currently a
trophy officer
boys boys boys boys so just so i'm
correct still played the majority of the
game we're not agreeing here oh no no i
love rory
the fact
that your argument is against trent's
defending i don't think it's as bad as
people make out come on man that's not
even not that's gonna happen not forget
to mention this james isn't a perfect
defender no it might be good and he
might even be better than trent but he's
certainly not perfect it was a valiant
effort but for me one nil down arm yeah
you're one note down nothing um trent
right so the hardest part is out the way
thank you very much
yeah man
so usually again we probably go to the
right center half but
bun that i'm gonna go to the front three
what are you doing
what are you doing let's get out of the
way no but this is this is this is
i want you to end well mate i'll do i'll
do the combining i'll do the combined
front three chelsea in liverpool
mohamed salah yeah on the right roberto
firmino yeah man sorry money yeah man
well get on this it might not even be
bobby for me you know of course it is no
no no i know what you're going to say no
i know what you're doing
right but i know he plays deeper right
yeah does he score enough goals or do
you not care about that this is why i
don't like the argument with city
getting so much plays for them winning
the league all the time we have
literally won the league the champions
league two champions league finals with
no striker bobby firmino it's not a
striker we're talking about him playing
there he please hear me and then he
actually plays it from there these two
cut inside and then we end up with the
results he's a classic for me
unbelievable technically unreal
creatively boss but on top of that you
cannot ignore the absolute brilliance
that's the algorithm has brought
something
down consistent numbers consistent good
performances and also some big goals as
well roberto firmino is everything i
want romelu lukaku to be i was desperate
for chelsea to sign the car yes i
thought he was the answer i really did i
think he's exactly what we need we won
the european cup we needed a striker to
lead the line somebody was desperate to
play for chelsea so we thought you know
there was footage of him as a 16 year
old walking around stanford bridge he
wanted to follow in the footsteps of
didier drug but all of that i thought
right lukaku is the man he will have
learned from his time under conte and
the do you remember the conversations
that people used to have about his time
at manchester united does he score
against big teams i thought that was
over
how's his first touch i thought that was
rectified
it turns out that
whether all of those questions are right
or wrong or whether they still exist
it doesn't matter because he doesn't
want to play for the club he has been a
totally disruptive presence and has
effectively ruined chelsea's season can
ask you this though who would your first
choice added to chelsea from freebie i
think our front three is kai havoc as a
false nine chelsea's best form this
season has been with kai havertz as a
footballer i agree with that he's the
only one that i could realistically put
on the table that you could then just
dismiss immediately yeah he's the one if
i put him on the table i don't look like
a complete [ __ ] if i put lukaku on the
table or i put well what am i going to
say hakim ziyish over muhammad
sallallahu it is peak for you to be here
yesterday
before which is sounds i've had loads of
stick before
um manny's the best left-winger in the
world
i don't know we've got neymar
not as consistent as manny and batman
play left wing yeah only just started
playing left wing i still think you've
got to edu money but it's not clear
where the challenge right now is cleared
like in my opinion clear the best player
in the world so i think we've got our
answers right the answer was never in
debate it's a lovely conversation but we
could have before we sat down stephen
and you put this together you could have
put three liverpool players up so go up
manny large you go there
can we just because you're throwing salt
into the wounds you're making me debate
things that don't need a debate i reckon
can you just put
andy robertson there and then and then
it's done because otherwise what are you
going to do you're going to start making
me make a case for mugs
of benjamin no yeah but he's been just
been injured yeah you know it was a
different if it was a different story
like that goes there of course it does
and i also think virgin van dyke is
obviously in this team yeah he's
obviously in this team so yeah can i
argue though and again devil's advocate
right here van dyke has he been as elite
as yeah
you're significantly bigger than i am so
i don't want to call you stupid
at the end of the day the only reason
why you might have dropped off a little
bit out of my team that way he's because
he was so flawless before but even since
he's came back i'm sorry he's led the
back line on the ball there's probably
no center back like him in the league so
here however we can we can talk
like this one i'm gonna fight for i'm
gonna make i'm gonna make it easy for
you
this is thiago silva
it's thiago silva
i love joel mata my giraffe
my girlfriend the wage nibbles new
players have you seen his little vlogs
joel matip is world clash top five
centre-backs in the league no doubt
about it but thiago silva miami is
outside of virgil vanza you're smiling
when you said that and i want to know
because you're a liverpool friend you
watch every week
is he that good he is not okay that's
good yeah
i remember on a previous episode on
another show that we've done on this
channel someone was trying to harry
maguire into those conversations shout
out to kg that being said
that being said in this one i will just
ask kg the comedian thiago silva is
unbelievable i've never ever ever never
did i think he was going to come to the
premier league and actually lead the
backline the way that he is amazing
no you're absolutely right
the way that he plays a game is it's
just unbelievable on the ball the
clearances that he makes off the ladder
and his pace the fact he can keep up
with this we've given him a new contract
already i think i'm like
do you know what i would actually go so
far as saying with him you know if you
were to do a chelsea all-time 11. i
think he's now in that kind of
conversation he is truly sensational
could you imagine these two together
they never considered a goal my man
literally left psg and won the champions
league at 36 by the way i am so sorry
did you know this back four you've got a
right back in terms of ability is
unbelievable centre-backs both can pass
both can actually go forward but they
can defend amazingly well and then
you've got rob as well with the energy i
think that back forward only regret with
tiago silva if we didn't ever
signed him when we should have done
never got that he would have been
partnered with john terry like it would
have been it would have been a dream
partnership they would have played so
well together all right boys we're going
to move on to holding midfield
are we talking about for being your
vases the third and the balance or reese
is the best in the world at what he does
and that wouldn't be henderson as
fabinho yeah no but the only one that
can actually compete with kante is
fabinho and i for me this is angola
kante i think angola kante is probably
one of chelsea's only two or three
genuinely world-class players what
angola kante does is unlike anything
i've ever seen before and i've been very
blessed in terms of the players i've had
the privilege of watching that he's on
stage
i've seen
i've seen michael essen on on on form
i've seen khloe macale at his best i've
seen players play in that position
obviously bad luck lampard central
midfielders but
angola kante is again probably in a
chelsea all time eleven i just don't see
how
any combined level this doesn't matter
whether it's chelsea liberal this is
chelsea anyone this is chelsea against
an all-stars of the world
and golocante makes it as a player i
think for being always actually probably
just edges kante as a dm
on the ball he's better than kante and i
think defensively there's not too much
of an argument but the two different
things
right even kentucky
the way that you're appraising uh
fabinho i kind of agree with and i
reckon if there was any if you were
having this debate with anyone who
didn't support chelsea i reckon fabinho
gets in i can't think i mean maybe maybe
i don't think i do
i don't think they do
what declan gets in there above all of
them by the way
it's not about yourself
[Applause]
so boys i think we've actually got a
decision there and i think it's kante
right two on the board the comeback is
on james that's fine that's fine i don't
even can't say i just i don't like it
you know what i mean thank you very much
thank you there you go cheers thank you
a bit more blue than i'd like to see one
sec let's have a look so two minutes
is
i feel like he's been very overheated
since he's joined the league and also
just because maybe he's not hitting the
standards what he was buying because of
his numbers which by the way he was
never getting and maybe that when he
came over you lot gassed him up so much
that you've now rightly saw like the
show he was tough three midfielders in
the world when we bought him and i still
think he's in that conversation are you
doing are you doing a pair or are you
just gonna well that's me
if you're putting tiago on the table i'm
i'm almost definitely going to agree
with you depending on who you're saying
next and then the next one has got to be
my captain jordan hendon nino captain of
my football club led us to multiple
trophies matteo kovich has been totally
overwhelmed i really like culver chit as
well the way that he carries the ball is
is fantastic the way that he transitions
into attack he's brilliant i think the
decision is yours because i think it's
kovichitch
plus
there is no other chelsea player i'm
going to put on the table why i don't
like this i don't think my edge
stretched me because because
gets in i like cold position but
in 20. that year i remember like arguing
that jordan henderson was the best
player of the league that year you know
what i'm stressing over it and it's only
because you mentioned some of me tiago
and kovach and the same if you that
would be insane
for my eyes that would be unbelievable
if we're going off the the the logistics
of the what these midfielders bring what
they've done i'm going to go with
henderson and tiago and i'm not changing
my mind like this is all up to me yeah
these two players are up to you i mean
that's why you were party yesterday yeah
you're not going to be totally frank as
well you haven't been a very good
definitive judge because it's been so
easy mate to be honest
the things i have said is just for a bit
of tv
and what i do want to say is for me
it's hendon okay it's hendo there so now
now you've made a really difficult but
now you've put yourself in a really
difficult position this bit easy
it's easy gotta you have one good cheese
this is it you know what this is easy
that's because you've bought into the
that's because you've brought into the
product
he said one good season and you went
yeah he won the league he won the
champions league last year
he had
he won the champions league last year he
won the game you're welcome sport babble
i've got it for you i've got it for you
um so i'm not doing this
but you can't not play the match
she's gonna make this a 20-minute video
this is the this is your moment you need
to build you can be
people are going to watch this and
they're going to they're going to judge
you on this yeah be the man you want to
be can't pay this deal it's covered he's
right tiago for me james you just got
getting his ears
don't do that
look one thing no changing mind exactly
don't do that sorry geez i'm sorry and i
hope he does next year become the tiago
that we all want him to be but this year
he hasn't been given yeah and not only
that he was crying the other day on live
tv give me more counter there you go
thank you
man i've still got one as well lads
captain marvel head dog hendon
okay
we are down to the final position the
goalkeeper now for me you got two of the
very best in this position in the world
i mean edward mendy's the best
goalkeeper in the world at the moment
he's the champion of the world champion
of europe champion of
africa he's a champion he's a champion
he's he's a champion i am sure you said
to me before we actually started to talk
about this proper this is going to be
easy i genuinely believed from all of my
heart that you were going to say
alison on the ball is better he's a
better shot stop at the name than the
mendy allison is obviously a brilliant
goalkeeper but i think the player that
he was
1920 i think she was a better goalkeeper
then he didn't have a particularly good
season last year he had a very rocky
season last year
he had a rocky spell he had a rocky
spell and that was the first rocky spell
that he's ever had since he's joined the
premier league otherwise from that rocky
spell maybe one mistake this season i'm
sorry allison has been flawless mate
let's fast forward this week you you've
put your case for me
i'm alison what are you going with steve
oh come on steve oh come on mate just
make a decision while we're still young
mendy's a trajectory uh i don't
brother i'm sorry
i'm sorry yeah
mendy
is also a beast
i'm just trying to find the will to live
no
come on i can't find it that is a
tragedy i'm sorry i think that's the top
of that andy nixon thank you very much
and on top of that the fact that we're
seeing four blue counters in this team
just goes to show that already we're
losing the credibility
i think you've done a good
great 11. i job you i think you've
pulled off our masterclass yeah well
done what a team this is we got there in
the end didn't we cheers
[Music]
what you've got to talk about the
context of how dominant man city have
been i'm not saying these things
invincibles and man united focus
invincibles it's easy to title a story
better than what it is it's easy to give
a a headline that's gonna draw eyes of
course the invincibles but manchester
city we're talking about a team that got
a hundred points rory when you talk
about someone you can talk to said alex
overall outside the premier league pep
guardiola